I'm Ed O'Keefe in Rhode Island where GOP
control of the Senate isn't on the mind
of Alan Fung he's running to help
Republicans retake the house have a
great day now thank you he's the former
mayor of Cranston Rhode Island and the
son of Chinese immigrants who grew up in
his family's restaurant now he's
campaigning on economic issues it's a
cost of living crisis that's hitting
every single individual in one hour
every single business owner on Allen
Fung is running for an open house seat
against Democrat Seth magaziner
Republicans are focused on picking up
this seat and several others and they're
trying to do it with the most diverse
class ever of house Republican
candidates 89 black latino Native
American and Asian contenders across the
country
Vegas
the GOP is also competing hard for seats
across New England Rhode Island for
example hasn't elected a republican to
Congress in more than 20 years
that's because the GOP brand is
unpopular here and isn't helped by
former president Donald Trump so he's
trying to keep his distance he hasn't
endorsed you right no he hasn't would
you like his endorsement would it help
the endorsement that's important for me
the people in this second district the
people of Rhode Island in 2020 who won
the presidential election no I hey look
I recognize Joe Biden is a legitimate
president two and a half hours away in
the suburbs of New York City Democratic
Congressman Sean Patrick Maloney is also
running in a tougher than anticipated
race I understand how to beat
Republicans in a tough seat he's facing
Republican Mike Lawler and millions of
dollars in GOP attack ads his lies are
costing you if they're going to blow
nine million dollars trying to beat me
that's nine million dollars they could
have spent winning some races somewhere
else part of the reason Maloney's a
favorite Republican Target is because
he's also in charge of getting other
Democrats elected to the house and he
says his party needs to find a way to
talk about the economy and issues
important to democratic voters like the
future of abortion rights family
budget's always on the ballot but you
know what you can't take away 50 years
of reproductive freedom and not and not
talk about it my God what would we be
doing if we weren't pushing back against
that
and Bob and I join us now at the table
in from the road and from the cold for
uh some insights into what you've been
learning let's start with you Bob uh
there are some big names out on the
campaign Trail some people call them
surrogates some people call them
political wingmen I think it's Ed's
terms what should we look for uh this
weekend as people make these big
speeches there are some surprises in the
works in the final days in fact late
last night just after I got off a bus
from northeastern Pennsylvania to New
York City to be here this morning Oprah
Winfrey through her support behind John
fetterman and Pennsylvania's toss-up of
a senate race big news yeah it really is
Dr Oz obviously something she had
supported in his TV career there and we
saw a president former president Trump
was in Iowa last night not a huge
surprise giving another signal to
Americans that he may be running again
let's take a look at a lesson
now in order to make our country
successful and safe and glorious
I will very very very probably do it
again okay
get ready that's all I'm telling you
very soon
get ready
get ready
that is someone who has talked to the
campaign lawyers who have said don't you
dare say it before election day because
it triggers some things but what does it
trigger when you look at some of the
Battleground States we're just days away
from well Democrats would love nothing
more for him to do it already and they
certainly know that it helps them
especially in these toss-up races in the
senate in the house but here's the thing
guys like Alan Fung who you just met in
that piece would probably if they win
this year would probably uh be in Far
More precarious situations two years
from now because a lot of the places
where Republicans are poised to win both
in Senate races Governors races house
races are the kind of places where the
GOP wasn't doing well when Donald Trump
was President right so that is the
ongoing yin and yang of the Republican
Party do we want control yes but it
requires electing Republicans who are
not at all like Donald Trump who Embrace
reality uh who are you know have
different opinions on immigration rights
on on other issues of concern and it's
part of why you may see despite the fact
you may run a big competition among
Republicans to see who should really be
their nominee welcome back from the road
and you'll be here Tuesday for our
election night coverage Ed Bob thank you
very much and uh speaking of election
night coverage we're gonna have full
election coverage here on CBS starting
at 8 pm Eastern on Tuesday that's
November 8th don't forget to vote